l'idée d'obtenir des implants de navire est
parfois un peu choquante pour les gens
quelqu'un m'a appelé des
mises à niveau de cyborg de Jésus électrique
[Musique]
Je le vois en quelque sorte comme ce que cela pourrait être Je
pense que cela commence par l'esprit curieux des
implants de micropuce ont été utilisés dans le
domaine médical  pendant des décennies, mais maintenant, on
estime que des centaines de milliers de personnes
dans le monde ont des implants à puce non médicalement nécessaires,
parfois appelés
biohacking
[Musique
] tout le monde n'est pas excité quand je
pense que oh c'est une puce et que je prévois que
ce n'est pas pour tout le monde mais ce n'est pas
obligé  être que les chips ne sont pas plus grosses
qu'un grain de riz au moins ici aux États-Unis,
il y a une idée de micropucer votre
chien ou votre animal de compagnie, donc s'ils sont perdus, vous
pouvez les ramener chez le vétérinaire et ils
peuvent les scanner et ça a comme  Coordonnées d'
identification du propriétaire c'est
essentiellement la même chose c'est à peu près
la taille d'un grain de riz cuit
l'implant est juste dans une
aiguille injectable creuse
et il va juste sous la peau
c'est comme g  Pour obtenir un piercing,
je voulais à l'origine en avoir un parce qu'il
vous donnait le contrôle d'accès pour bien déverrouiller votre
porte. Je ne porte plus de clés.
C'est ma porte d'entrée. Elle est verrouillée.
C'est le clavier Samsung.
il suffit de prendre mon
implant de transpondeur, de le
mettre là, le
tour est joué. J'étais très curieux de savoir comment
cela fonctionnait, que pouviez-vous faire d'autre
avec, combien de données vous pouviez réellement
stocker dessus, donc j'ai trois
implants à puce jusqu'à présent, j'en ai un dans la
sangle dans  ma main, une sur le dessus de ma
main et une sur mon avant-bras, a commencé
avec celle de la sangle dans ma main,
essentiellement, elles sont toutes RFID ou NFC,
qui est juste cette
communication en champ proche, elle n'est pas connectée à
Internet, c'est ce que beaucoup de  les gens
pensent que c'est le cas, il n'est pas actif, ce
qui signifie qu'il n'a pas de batterie en moi, il n'émet pas
toujours de signal, c'est
passif, j'ai mes coordonnées liées à
celui-ci en particulier et la bonne chose à
propos d'avoir la LED apparaît et  montre
où il est  dans le lecteur et ensuite cela
vous amènera à ma page Web
[Musique]
mes parents nous encouragent toujours comme si
nous étions curieux comme chaque fois que j'aurais de
nouveaux jouets comme je voudrais
les démonter pour comprendre comme comment fonctionnent-
ils comment  ont-ils bougé, ils ont pu
fabriquer et faire exploser des trucs et avoir peu d'
électricité comme des projets scientifiques
et j'ai adoré cette partie de mon
enfance
mon travail de marcheur de jour est en tant qu'ingénieur logiciel
dans l'industrie du jeu et la
nuit je fais du cosplay je travaille sur Lego je  faire de
l'impression 3D Je fais de la CNC Je fais du piratage éthique par
satellite
étranger
moi-même une personne artistique ou créative
sans l'utilisation de n'importe quel type de
technologie
[Musique]
aime faire des trucs de cosplay comme si je
pouvais faire fonctionner mon implant de puce avec un
accessoire de cosplay pour que je puisse  prenez-le et
il s'allumerait, ce serait incroyable,
mon idée était comme si ce
n'était probablement pas la pire chose que j'ai mise dans mon
corps, que puis-je faire d'autre avec ces
implants et cela a conduit au voyage d'
obtenir le Tesla im  plante et en quelque sorte
faire mon propre
étranger le
faire avant que ce ne soit pas quelque chose que vous
pouvez simplement aller sur Internet et taper
dans un moteur de recherche
[Musique]
donc quand j'ai eu ma voiture, ils sont venus avec
ces
euh ces clés de voiturier et des gens très similaires
voient peut-être  cela ressemble à
une clé d'hôtel mais il y a une puce NFC à l'
intérieur de cette carte mais la chose la plus importante
pour cela était l'antenne et j'avais
besoin de l'antenne pour pouvoir lire
et communiquer car c'est la même chose que celle-ci et la
même chose que mes implants de puce là-bas  n'est pas
euh c'est qu'il est passif il n'y a pas de
batterie dedans donc vous devez être très
très proche donc pour référence d'échelle
c'est la taille des deux autres
implants à puce que j'ai actuellement dans mon
corps celui de Tesla pour l'échelle est la taille
de cette minifig LEGO pas la largeur
mais la longueur donc j'ai pris la
carte Tesla Valley originale et je l'ai
fondue dans de l'acétone j'ai extrait la puce
qui était dans la carte puis j'ai créé ma
propre antenne puis au cas où ça dans un
biopolymère sûr pour  r le corps
et ensuite
je l'ai injecté sous la couche dermique de ma peau
parfois c'est un peu difficile à dire mais
euh tu tapes dessus ici et ensuite tu
ouvres la porte comme si cette
clé était en moi donc je tapais derrière le
porte-gobelet pour  m'authentifier et ensuite
je serais capable de conduire une fois que j'aurais mis ma
ceinture de sécurité,
alors quand j'ai travaillé sur le piratage de Tesla, j'ai eu
des réactions négatives de cet endroit merveilleux
appelé Internet,
certaines personnes ont dit oh alors maintenant je n'ai plus besoin
de voler vos clés de voiture  Je peux juste
me couper le bras, je suis comme un meurtre sûr dans Grand
Theft Auto comme
très dur quand les gens vous envoient du courrier haineux,
quelqu'un m'a envoyé des pages déchirées de
la Bible chrétienne qui semblent déjà
malveillantes, donc la partie qu'ils ont
mise en évidence et envoyée et a dit  à moins qu'il
n'ait la marque qui est le nom de la
Bête ou le nombre de son nom cela
s'appelle la sagesse si quelqu'un a la
Perspicacité qu'il calcule le nombre de la
Bête car c'est un nombre d'homme son
nombre est 666. une femme vêtue de  un
fils avec e  la lune sous ses pieds et une
couronne de 12 étoiles sur sa tête elle était
enceinte et cria de douleur alors qu'elle
était sur le point d'accoucher le dragon se
tenait devant la femme qui était sur le
point d'accoucher afin qu'il puisse la dévorer en
premier  enfant au moment où il est né, elle a
donné naissance à un fils, un enfant mâle qui
régnerait sur toutes les nations avec un
sceptre de fer, alors ils m'ont envoyé un test de grossesse
disant essentiellement que je suis comme la
chute de
cette femme dans le dragon ou quelque chose que je
je ne sais pas
très très bizarre Puis suivi par des
choses vraiment sympas de petites filles
que j'ai inspirées pour la tige ou pour des
trucs Lego comme la lettre de comme les enfants
comme ça c'est chouette comme
et les gens disent comme hé tu as inspiré mes
enfants ou toi  inspiré ma petite fille à
ce qu'ils puissent s'habiller et vous savez avoir une
représentation de ce qu'ils veulent être
et
euh font toujours les choses qu'ils aiment c'est
plutôt chouette
pour que je puisse voir où nous allons
donc nous nous dirigeons vers une puce  implants
avec chat cette puce wil  Je fais tout,
des paiements à l'authentification en passant par l'authentification à
deux facteurs ubiqui et votre Tesla,
j'ai fait quelques mesures sur cette
taille de puce, ce n'est pas aussi gros qu'une
minifig Lego mais c'est dans un diamètre donc c'est
un cercle je pense que c'est comme 22
millimètres donc je suppose que cela
devra être fait avec des incisions ou des
points de suture
n'aiment généralement pas la douleur
je sais que cela semble ironique mais quand vous voulez
quelque chose la douleur est très différente je
vous sens dans la vraie vie nous avons beaucoup d'échanges
amis qui sont dans la cybersécurité
non je suis un défenseur des développeurs
oh attends je pense que je ne savais pas que d'
accord
tu peux passer en premier de cette façon chat nous pouvons
avoir un traumatisme partagé
merci j'apprécie que
tu sois un vrai soldat Amy  Je peux
supporter la douleur
[Musique]
ce qui était pire en le regardant avant et en
sachant ou non euh non ce n'était pas mal du tout de
te regarder
mon amie Charlotte a aussi quelques
implants et euh
elle est extrêmement intéressée par les plus
gros qu'elle n'a pas '  je ne sais pas exactement ce que je
reçois  elle sait juste que j'en prends
un plus gros qu'elle n'en a, je veux dire
intéressant de voir si euh TSA a
quelque chose à dire à ce sujet euh celui-ci est
plus gros ouais parce que celui-ci est tellement
plus gros que c'est ce dont je serais
curieux de me faire savoir  comment ça se passe,
je vais ouais
[Musique] la
plupart des puces peuvent être installées rapidement avec
un injecteur ou une aiguille de perçage, mais les
nouvelles puces qu'Amy et Cat obtiennent
sont une puce expérimentale plus grande qui
nécessite une incision et des points de
suture comme la LED fonctionne encore  Je suis comme
probablement pas je suis comme trop sanglant ouais
trop sanglant trop
gonflé je suis rouge ah oh c'est déjà bien
mieux que ma Tesla
l'indicateur LED est comme super utile
ouais il clignote en vert
c'est si mignon laissez-moi voir que c'est  alors dope
ouais c'est sûr que
ce n'est pas une nouvelle technologie comme si elle existait
depuis très très longtemps ouais et
avoir ces choses est la raison pour laquelle les
gens comme les puces de suivi 5G dans les
vaccins j'ai l'impression que j'aimerais que ce soit je
j'aimerais souhaiter de la merde sacrée  les gens  Nous pensons toujours
que ces puces sont comme
connectées à Internet à tout moment,
comme si elles étaient alimentées et
connectées à Internet et que quelqu'un
vous suit à distance oh mon Dieu, ce
serait tellement malade que c'est comme
m'inscrire il y a aussi eu  J'ai eu de bonnes
discussions avec des gens, je suis comme d'
accord, non, il ne se connecte pas à
Internet, mais si c'était le cas, en mettriez-vous
un comme vos enfants ou quelque chose
comme ça et puis cela apporte
quelque chose que ce soit un  invasion de la
vie privée ou est-ce comme une sécurité comme
l'éthique morale
euh je suppose qu'il y a des
arguments politiques qui entrent là-dedans je pense
que c'est contraire à l'éthique parce qu'il devient
trop facile d'en abuser mais ça mais c'est
le point comme avoir ces conversations de
bonnes conversations viennent  à partir de là, je
suis sûr ou j'aime simplement mettre un
processus de pensée différent dans l'esprit des gens
au moins comme si je n'essayais
pas d'en mettre un en vous ou de vous
faire rejoindre ma non-culture mais
ouais n  o cette chose est comme pour moi, c'est
strictement comme si c'était une chose de sécurité euh
parce que si vous devez me couper le bras
pour obtenir mes mots de passe à usage unique alors et
peut-être que vous l'avez mérité, c'est ce que les gens
disent pour ma voiture ils le seront  comme oh alors maintenant
nous devons comme
euh te couper le bras et c'est
Grand Arm Auto ou quelque chose que j'étais comme si
j'étais comme oui eh bien on devient comme un
meurtre et on est comme
voler mes clés ouais
mais aussi c'est juste plutôt cool mais  il
a aussi une LED ouais c'est tellement mignon c'est
juste que c'est juste cool
certaines personnes pensent que c'est bizarre d'avoir un
implant de puce mais d'une certaine manière je regarde
l'industrie de la beauté je vois des publicités sur les
réseaux sociaux tout le temps comme vous le savez c'est si
courant maintenant  pour les femmes d'avoir du Botox et du
remplissage et c'est considéré comme le signe de la
beauté et
euh même dans la chirurgie plastique comme je
pense que c'est tellement intéressant que certaines de
ces choses sont totalement acceptables et
normales mais avoir un implant à puce c'est
comme oh
ce n'est pas normal toi  voyez comment je clignote en
rouge
là nous  allez-y si j'essaie de
vous convaincre d'obtenir un implant à puce comme si c'était
finalement votre choix Je n'essaie pas d'
aimer vous gagner à mes côtés si je peux
juste vous éduquer et que vous pouvez prendre votre
propre décision éclairée alors j'ai
déjà fait quelque chose pour vous faire penser
d'une manière différente